And now it's the old scout master.
So we went camping last month-
Springtime can be unpredictable.
We lined up to stand a cabin down at our camp,
Had a nice warm fire going and everything like that,
But it just kept snowing, and snowing, and snowing.
It was horrible outside.
It was windy and cold,
Snow blowing all over the place.
All the scouts could do is just stand there and look through the window.
They did that all day and then kind of late in the afternoon
I said to my assistant scout master.
I said I wonder if we should let him in the cabin now.
Hey, this is podcast number 67.
Music.
Welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
So from the Great White North, Tom Hawkeye Brewer writes in
from the 3rd Orleans Beaver Colony in Ottawa, Canada.
Honestly, we come up to Algonquin Park every summer
and I love being up in Canada.
I love the folks up there.
Anyway, Tom wrote in and said this:
I'm a second year beaver scout leader from Canada,
That's ages five to seven
And I have some experience with all of the questions
that you asked last time and I wanted to answer one.
I was a new leader and the person I was replacing
wasn't excited about my new program,
Year one. I ran the program my way
and she was still involved
and I tried to accept some of her feedback.
You know it went okay
but I know I made a number of mistakes.
The second year our numbers doubled
and I was able to involve this leader
to help in areas where I knew she was a lot more capable
and that was crafts
and working with the special needs scouts,
And this has really improved our colony.
Now next year she's going to move on
into our scout section after seven years
in the beaver colony
and if we continue to grow, next year
that old leader who now is giving advice might be me.
I hope I'll be able to counsel and direct where required
and do it as graciously as the leader who's moving on.
Thanks for the podcast.
Even though my youth are way younger,
many of the lessons still apply
Well. thanks for getting in touch, Tom.
I know there's a number of people that listen
to the podcast up there in Canada
and who read the blog,
and I'm always interested to hear from folks.
Tom is working with what would be Tiger and Wolf Cubs
in the BSA,
So that gives us a little bit of an idea
of the group that they're working with
and I'm happy to hear that a lot of us
manage to apply across the program.
Thanks again, Tom, for being in touch.
Now I'm catching up on emails and comments
and messages and things like that.
Well, I'm working away on the blog and the website.
so be patient with me.
If I didn't get to your message this week,
make sure to get to it next week.
You can get in touch at ScoutmasterCG
at Verizonnet.
That's the email
And then the website in the blog is ScoutmasterCGcom.
C-G Clark Green, C-G.
There we go
This time around at Scout Master's Ship
in seven minutes or less.
we're going to talk about a very simple yet effective way
of training and mentoring youth leaders
and then we're going to answer an email
from the Golden Empire Council
out there in Placerville, California,
about service hours.
So that's enough for this podcast, I think,
Do you?
I'm glad you agree.
Let's get started, shall we?
Scout Master's Ship in seven minutes
or less.
So here's a picture that forms in my mind
when I look at most of our attempts
at youth leadership training.
I see a claw machine.
You remember these?
I know they're still around.
They're there at the department store
or the pizza parlor or the amusement park
and you got to throw quarters in the darn thing.
and then they have this set of controls,
that controls like a crane-like claw
that goes in and catches the big prizes
and you know, then you win a prize.
You never win the 17-joule boulevard watch.
More than likely you win the little plastic skeleton,
And if you perfectly understand what I'm talking about,
you're probably pretty old.
But anyway, that's kind of the impression that I get
when I watch us try and use formal training events
and syllabuses and all that type of stuff
to train youth leaders.
Training at one remove from the actual situation-
I mean where they're going to actually use
the skills that they need-
is about as effective as the controls on that claw machine.
Most training tends to favor this kind of abstract explanation
and remote analysis over direct action.
If we sit in a room and we look at videos
and PowerPoint presentations
and we listen to the Scoutmaster talk,
there's not going to come a whole lot of that.
A whole lot is not going to come out of that,
Not anywhere near as much as actually being in the moment
and having the responsibility of leadership
and giving it a go.
You know you can't teach a child to ride a bike
by showing them a video and a PowerPoint presentation
or by just talking them through it.
You know they have to sit on the bike
and a dad runs along or mom runs along
with a hand on the back of the bike,
keeping them steady for a while.
Well, just steer that way a little bit.
You know how it works.
Have you ever taught anybody to ride a bike
or drive a car, which is a whole other animal?
You know what I'm talking about.
There's just so much that can be done abstractly.
Most of it is down to action.
They've got to give it a try,
Given the opportunity to go out
and do really compelling, interesting things.
Scouts train themselves in leadership.
They don't need to be manipulated
by the points of this and the 11 steps of that.
They need to get out and give stuff a good, honest try.
That's what they're clamoring to do.
That's why they joined Scouts.
They didn't join Scouts to sit in a room,
listen to you talk and watch another video.
They want to do real stuff,
And when they do real stuff,
that's how they learn to lead.
And this process is pretty simple.
It's action, reflection and discovery.
Action, reflection and discovery.
And it's the best way to get complex concepts understood
Because it's very experiential.
So this is how it works.
You act, you have a very basic knowledge of what you're doing.
Hey, those guys need to line up.
So they go and they give that a try
And they either succeed or they fail.
And then you do a little bit of reflection on that.
Well, how did that go?
Not real well. Nobody listened to me.
Well, why do you figure they didn't listen to you?
I don't know,
But maybe because I'm about the same age as they are
and they don't appreciate things.
And then we have a period of discovery,
which is all right. well, if that didn't work real well for you,
what are you going to try next time?
Or maybe you should give this a shot.
Do you see what I'm saying?
And a thousand little instances,
a thousand little instances of mentoring through this action,
reflection and discovery process,
or what is going to make a real leader?
There's some uncertainty involved in this,
And we often talk about the fact that
scout leaders. we don't like a lot of uncertainty,
But that's what the process is.
It's uncertain.
It's a little more difficult than doing the training event,
But the training event is going to result in about 3%
of what this kind of active training is going to do.
So how does a newly minted patrol leader
learn his job?
I think it's basically the same way that you learn how to repel,
If you've ever been repelling. what happens is
there's a little discussion,
It's very brief, 5 or 10 minutes,
Safety points.
Here's how you put on the harness. wear your helmet,
don't turn upside down, you know, wear a pair of gloves.
Then you climb up on the wall.
You know you're reminded of a couple of commands.
You put on the edge and say: go for it,
Go ahead,
Start letting a little rope out,
Go down
There. you go,
Try jumping out a little bit,
Jump out right,
And you might be petrified the whole time,
but somebody's kind of mentoring you through it.
But you're doing all the actions,
You're the one who's making it happen
And you get down to the bottom of the repelling board
and you might think, wow, that was kind of fun,
I'm going to try that again.
I bet you I can do it better next time.
And so you automatically fall into this acting,
reflecting and then discovering mode.
I think it's pretty easy to understand.
We need to watch out as adults, that we observe all this
from a respectful distance,
because our presence changes any situation.
for a scout leader,
That's right.
For a youth leader, it changes any situation
they find themselves in.
And here's why
Adults, you know, in the world of boys, in our culture
at this moment, are the default leaders,
no matter where they are.
If it's sports, if it's school, you know
scouts, whatever things they're occupied with
at home or at church,
If an adult's in the room, they're the default leader.
So our observation post has got to be a fair distance away.
We need to be watching carefully
And then we need to teach and to inculcate
in each one of our leaders this process
of action, reflection and discovery:
Action, reflection and discovery-
And it doesn't need to be called that
and don't you dare turn it into a PowerPoint presentation
for them.
Just actually do this,
Actually do this and they will pick it up.
Actually do it with them and they will pick it up.
None of the scouts in my troop has any idea
of the action, reflection, discovery method,
because it's just something that we do. naturally,
If I asked them to explain it,
they wouldn't be able to explain it in those terms,
But they would know.
Well, I try something and then we, you know,
we sit down and we talk about it a little bit
and we discover better ways to do it.
And it doesn't take long before they catch on.
and now they're training themselves.
Now they're making things happen themselves
and they're also exercising this with other scouts.
So action, reflection, discovery,
It works.
It's a good way to train youth leaders
And I challenge you to go ahead and put it to the test.
Ooh, ooh, ooh.
If you've ever wandered lonely through the world,
Write me a letter, send it by name
Email, that is folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
So there you are. you're at a troop meeting,
Your things are going just fine.
A scout comes up to you and says:
you know I need to do a service project for second class
And you think you do.
Oh right,
Yeah, of course you do.
You can't really remember the requirement verbatim.
So you take a look in his book and it says this:
For requirement number five, it says:
participate in an approved minimum of one hour service project.
And he's asking you to tell him what the service project is
and who approves it.
And you might be caught a little flat-footed.
Now I heard from Tim Aiken,
who's a scout master in troop 88
in the Golden Empire Council in Placerville, California
And Tim wrote in asking a question about this.
He said: just wondering if you could say a few words
about service projects and service hours.
As a scout master, I get to field all the questions
about what qualifies and what doesn't.
I apply a basic test.
I mean, do the hours better for the community,
or just the BSA, or just one family, et cetera.
Do you have any thoughts on this?
By the way, I've enjoyed all of your 66 podcasts.
Keep them coming.
Well, thanks, Tim.
Thanks for being in touch,
And that's a really good question
because I think this is one that comes up really quite often.
So the service projects we're talking about
are for second class and for star and for life rank
And before we read the requirements,
these requirements are really simple and open-ended
for a very good reason:
They have to be surmountable challenges for every scout,
no matter where he lives in the country,
no matter his family situation,
no matter where he goes to school, whatever.
So that's why these requirements are very simple and open-ended.
When most of us encounter something like this in scouting-
one of these really open-ended general statements-
we start to look for definitions.
You know, the simple answer just doesn't seem right
And we're left with two options:
Either accept the simple answer
or you come up with a set of definitions and rules
that provide a complex and slightly more satisfying answer.
Let's just accept the simple answer in this case.
So let's just read the requirements very, very briefly here,
because they are very brief.
Second class, requirement number five:
participate in an approved minimum of one hour service project.
And for star and life ranks,
they're both requirement number four
and they're both worded exactly the same,
except for star says while a first class scout
and life says while a star scout
take part in service projects
totaling at least six hours of work,
These projects must be approved by your scout master.
That's it,
Very few words.
The only other official advice or definition
of either of those is on page 27
of the advancement committee guide,
which you will find a link to a PDF version of said guide
in the post that contains this podcast,
And it says this: for star and life ranks,
a scout must perform six hours of service to others.
This may be done as an individual project
or as a member of a patrol or a troop project.
Star and life service projects may be approved.
for scouts assisting on Eagle service projects.
The scout master approves the project before it is started.
Same page, same book says this:
For the second class rank,
a scout must participate in a service project
or projects approved by his scout master.
The time of the service must be a minimum of one hour.
This project prepares a scout
for the more involved service projects
he must perform for the star life and Eagle scout ranks.
So all three say something like participate in or take part in.
That's simple.
This is something the scout does as a participant.
It doesn't say that he has to plan or lead these projects.
He could, but that's not a requirement.
All three mention service projects.
There's no real modification of the term
to indicate it must be a certain type of project
or who benefits from the project.
If you got a hold of the advancement committee guidelines book
and you read about the fact that if you didn't read carefully
you might come away with the assumption
that they have to participate in an Eagle project,
Well, that's not so.
It's just suggested that, hey,
there's one possible way of fulfilling the requirement.
And all three give a minimum number of hours
that must be completed to qualify
to have the requirement fulfilled.
And all three require that the scout master approve
of the project before they're started
Now. why is that?
Well, we don't want scouts participating in activities
that are unsafe, you know,
like roadside cleanups, with no safety consideration
comes to mind, or inappropriate.
So we're asked to vet the project before they're started.
I have several standing approvals for projects,
Eagle projects, a guy participating in an Eagle project-
my scouts know that that's good
and that will fulfill the requirement for you.
A service role in school or church is good too.
You know, maybe they're an altar server
or an usher at church,
Maybe they're a member of the student council at school
or something like that.
Or a family organized project.
I will sign off on any of those
and I have kind of a standing approval on those.
There's no real reading between the lines
or looking for modifying statements with these.
They just don't exist.
So these service hours can be fulfilled
in a wide variety of ways.
The only real restriction to note
is that we're not allowed to modify
or take away from any advancement requirement,
So we can't go in and make modifications to those.
We have to take them at face value.
It's understood that the service
being rendered benefits others.
Those others could be the scouts' family,
specific groups, specific individuals,
organizations or the general public.
The service may be rendered as a part of
an organized project, like an Eagle project,
or as part of a regular commitment,
like, as I said, being an altar server
or an usher at church
or something the scout comes up with,
like picking up trash around his neighborhood.
We want our scouts to serve all the time
to benefit the community throughout their lives,
And the very minimal service requirements
for these ranks are a pretty good start.
We want it to stay simple and rewarding
and we don't want to overlay it
with tons of rules and regulations,
And that's why this requirement
is a good open-ended requirement.
When a scout asks me what he can do
for a service project,
I try and turn the question back on him
and I ask him what he has in mind
If he says that.
well, how about if I take out the trash
once a week at home?
And I'll ask him: you know
what's the difference between that
and your mother making dinner every night?
Does your mother get service hours
for making dinner every night?
No, Well, why not?
Well, that's just something she does.
Well, it's part of her responsibility
to the family, right? Yes,
The trash is a good service project.
Oh, no, I see, I see.
So what would be a good service project,
And you know we kind of poke around
with questions like that until they arrive
at a good conclusion.
Maybe we can make some suggestions along the way.
But if you need to be able to,
if your interest is being able to judge
what is a qualifying project
and what isn't, I think that's pretty simple.
It's going to be something
voluntarily, it's going to be something
that he does not get enumerated for,
It's not something, you know,
that's part of a paid job or something like that.
You know, and as far as the direction of the service,
there's no qualifying statements
anywhere that I can find.
So the direction of the service,
if it seems appropriate to you, go for it.
We want Scouts to develop
a habit that will become part of their lives,
And I think any active Scout
will have a lot of difficulty identifying
and carrying out these very minimal service projects,
And I think most of them will have
several to choose from
Now, before we stop. there are a number of
urban legends about service projects
that just seem to come up again and again,
And they seem to stem
from some of the rules for Eagle projects-
And we're not talking about Eagle projects right now
Because that's a separate conversation.
But there are some rules around Eagle projects
that seem to somehow.
People kind of look at those and they assume
that they apply to these other service projects
And they don't. They don't.
For instance,
service projects for Eagle
can't be directed at the Scout camp
or the Scout property.
It can't directly benefit Scouting
in that way.
But there's no such stricture
for the second-class Star in Life projects.
It doesn't restrict you
doing a workday at camp
or something like that to fulfill
the service project requirement.
Eagle projects have to be planned
and carried out by the Scout,
But not for the other projects.
That's not mentioned anywhere.
There's this idea that
it would be a good idea to have
a Star in Life Scouts
formally plan and carry out
their six-hour service project
to prepare them for the Eagle project.
You can't do that.
It's not a good idea. but it's not a good idea
because it's not a requirement
and we don't add to or take away from
any of the rank requirements.
It's not allowed.
The other myth that
sometimes gets handed down
is that all the service hours
have to be dedicated to a single project,
And that's not true either.
They can be accumulated over participation
in several projects.
I think we get the point.
Sometimes there are things that
not defined very well in Scouting.
The reason they're not defined
that closely is because
they need to be open-ended
enough so Scouts all over the country,
in all these different types of conditions,
can meet them. They're also simple,
because we want them to be simple.
We don't want to put a lot of hoops
in front of our Scouts to jump through.
We want them to go ahead and get the
requirement taken care of.
Especially with this one, I think the central thing,
the central goal that we're trying to establish,
is rendering real service to the community
and also inculcating
in our Scouts this habit
of service to others.
So, Tim, I hope that helps
And if you
out there have any
opinions or additions
or disagreements about what you've just heard,
make sure to get in touch.
Well, thanks again for listening.
Here's how to keep in touch.
Read the Scoutmaster blog at ScoutmasterCGcom,
where you can also
subscribe to the Scoutmaster newsletter,
And the newsletter is
a monthly digest of the Scoutmaster blog
and podcast with some great
Scouting resources around a monthly theme,
And the newsletter goes out
by email once a month.
And then you can
read the Scoutmaster blog at ScoutmasterCGcom,
where you can also subscribe
by email once a month,
And every newsletter includes
a giveaway from one of our affiliate sponsors.
As I mentioned last time,
the April giveaway,
which is going to be drawn
this week, is for
a little bug stove-
A little bug wood stove. There's a review
of that wood stove
at ScoutmasterCGcom.
Take a look.
You can subscribe to the Scoutmaster podcast
on iTunes when you do, feel free
to leave a comment or review or a rating,
And if you're interested, you can
call and leave a voicemail
message that will then become
part of the Scoutmaster podcast.
That's right. You can call in with a comment
or a question, Record it
via voicemail
And then it might end up on the next podcast.
You never know. The number to call
is 484-734-0002..
That's
484-734-0002.
You can follow us
at Scoutmaster blog on Facebook
and ScoutmasterCG
on Twitter.
You can email me, Clark Green,
with your comments and questions
at ScoutmasterCG.
ScoutmasterCG
at Verizonnet.
I want to remind you that Scoutmaster
blog and the Scoutmaster podcast are not
official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America.
Hey, it's just me talking into a microphone.
That's right. I'm trying to lend
a hand to scout leaders and have a little
bit of fun along the way.
Before we go, let's hear from our founder
Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert, Good luck to you
and good camping.
Thank you, sir. Until next time,
Thank you.